[موسيقى]
اهلا نادين اهلا وسهلا تحيه طيبه لكما
ولجميع مشاهدين مساء العربيه نقول لكم
الصوت والصور اليوم من هنا من مكه المكرمه
بتحديم الحرم المكي الشريف من بوابه مئه
في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه طبعا
بالتاكيد هذا خلفي باب مئه وهو الباب الذي
لا يغلق في مكه المكرمه وفي الحرم المكي
الشريف وهو اكبر باب في العالم طبعا يتكون
من ثلاث ابواب بجانب بعض يدخل منها الزوار
وقاصدي المسجد الحرام من هذه المنطقه وهو
يعتبر اكبر مدخل الى الحرم المكي الشريف
طبعا بحديثنا عنه اتركه لكم الان الصوره
من امام هذا الباب الذي يعتبر اكبر باب في
العالم اليوم نتحدث ايضا عن استكمال اعمال
تهيئه التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بنسبه
100% بما فيها بادوارها الخمسه وايضا
الاسطح والدور الارضي الاستقبال المصلين
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه تستقبل وتتسع
لحوالي مليون و200 الف مصرح حسب احصائيات
الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد
النبوي بحديثنا اليوم ايضا عن تجهيز
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه لاستقبال الزوار
وقاصدي المسجد الحرام نحن نتحدث عن
الخدمات المقدمه لهذه الاعداد الغفيره من
الزوار
والمعتمرين هذه الخدمات التي تتمثل في
الخدمات الصحيه الانسانيه الاجتماعيه
وايضا خدمات كثيره تقدم لهم في في اطار
خدمه الحجاج والمعتمرين في السعوديه
السعوديه قدمت الدعم الكبير جدا للحجاج
والمعتمرين وبحديثنا اليوم من مكه المكرمه
نستقبل غدا العشر الاواخر هنا في الحرم
المكي الشريف هذه الخدمات التي تقدم لهم
لاجل ان يعيشوا هذه التجربه بشكل مثالي
وبشكل يضمن لهم ان يعيشوا بيسر وطمانينه
ايضا جميع الجهات الموجوده هنا وجميع
الوكالات المسانده مع رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
قدموا هذه الخدمات للزوار والمعتمرين لكي
يعيشواسر وسهوله نعم
يعني اليوم فقط لكي نضع نقاط على الحروف
ومع اقتراب العشر الاواخر للشهر الفضيل
توافذ هذه الاعداد الكبيره من المعتمرين
نتحدث اكثر بالنقاط استعدادات والارشادات
الموصى بها حتى اليوم
نتحدث اليوم نادين وسهام عن اكثر من 17
مليون زائر معتمر وصلوا حتى اليوم الى مكه
المكرمه الاستعدادات الوارده بالتاكيد
اولا استعدادات لتقديم سقيا زمزم عدد
النترات التي قدمت الى اليوم 25 مليون لتر
من مياه زمزم هناك ايضا عدد من ستقدم
مكثفه بالتاكيد لخدمه زوار وقاصدي المسجد
الحرام ايضا خدمه تقديم وجبات الافطار
هناك تنافس كبير جدا بين الجمعيات
المتواجده هنا وايضا عدد من المؤسسات
الخيريه لتقديم الوجبات وجبات الافطار
للزوار وقاصدي المسجد الحرام نتحدث ايضا
عن تطهير وتنظيف وتعقيم سجاديد المسجد
الحرام وفرش المسجد الحرام نتحدث ايضا عن
فتح الابواب ابواب المطاف السته هي باب
الملك عبد العزيز باب الملك فهد باب الفتح
وباب العمره وباب الزبير وباب السلام تم
فتحها بالكامل للمعتمرين وايضا سته ابواب
اخرى هي 91 و 89.87 و88 للمصلين
عن هذه الابواب التي تحدثنا عنها 12 باب
كلها لان يعيش هذا الزائر المعتمر تجربه
مثاليه اثناء وصوله الى المسجد الحرام
الان صحن المطاف ممتلئ بالكامل ونتحدث
اليوم ايضا عن توافد الكثير من الزوار
والمعتمرين الى المسجد الحرام نتحدث الان
ايضا من التوسعه بعد اكتمالها ايضا باعداد
المصلين والزوار العشر الاواخر بالتاكيد
ستشهد ازدحاما اكثر وهذا بالتاكيد ما تضعه
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والجهات المسانده في
عين الاعتبار لخدمتهم بشكل مناسب سلمنا
على المعتمرين يا اسامه كله عم بيسلم من
وراك الى اللقاء اسامه القاسم كلهم
موجودين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات